Julie every young artist dreams of
creating a ripple and you know now with
the internet with Twitter and things can
just be sort of instantaneous all over
the world at a push of a button do you
remember the first time that you said I
want to create a ripple in the world I
want to do something that affects people
whether I'm known for it or not but I
just want to be part of something well
the first thing that comes to my mind is
not it not exactly what you're asking
but is that I lived in LA and when the
smog was very very bad and I would get
up every morning and listen to the radio
station and they would come on and the
announcer would be what I call selling
the weather and say and in Los Angeles
today there is no smog and I'd be like
oh my god was so I tried to figure out
how to address that in film and I didn't
do very well um doing it in a kind of
you know what head on way so I finally
was able to do it with humor and I had
it was a you know just kind of straight
exploitation picture about called it was
summer school teachers and and so they
this girl gets up in the morning and she
raises the window and looks out at the
smog and coughs and the radio announcer
comes on and says in the Los Angeles
today there is no smog and it always
gotta laugh but I thought maybe somebody
thought about it afterward I didn't give
up I'm very persistent I think you have
to be as a producer and I decided that I
was going to track down who was allowing
the radio stations to say there's no
smog in LA today when clearly oh I
forgot after he says there's no strong
today the girl coughs so she raises the
window sees the smog the radio announcer
comes on and says in Los Angeles today
there is no smog and she coughs so I
tracked down a foot through the radio
station I started by
find them and saying why are you saying
there's no smog and they said well
because the I think was that called the
Air Quality Management District in those
days has levels below which they say
it's not smog and I said levels for what
and they said well they only measure for
things so it turned out there were some
things that were very carcinogenic that
might be a very high levels but they
would still be within the rights to say
no smog because it didn't appear on the
list of what was being monitored by the
AQMD then I went to the state and and
reached the head of the Air Quality
Management District and took him to
breakfast and said this should not be
allowed to happen and you know it and
then Jerry Brown appointed me to her to
the Air Resources Board anyway it's a
much longer story but yes I thought in
kind of my naivete but on the other hand
eventually people did make a difference
so I wasn't the only one who was going
that route and trying to think about it
whereas before that I think there had
been a different attitude about smog
which I discovered when my mother told
me she thought it was crazy just to try
to do anything about smog I of course
thought she was crazy to even suggest
that I shouldn't try to do something
about small and finally I said to her
one day when she made the comment as we
were driving into Los Angeles I get so
excited when I smelled the smog I said
mother why and she said because it means
jobs so my mother had lived through the
depression so she looked at smoke a
completely different way than I did
eventually she came to see things my way
I know there's a lot of people with old
cars that have really fought that
California smog laws because it's so
hard to get an older car
smart and to have it path anyway they
stopped announcing no smog today they
stop that so at least accomplish that
and and so what would you tell a young
person that wants to create a ripple and
whether it's something creative or two
you know better the air quality well I
think what I see and think about for my
children and what I think about you know
looking back on my time of you know
being young like in my 20s and my 30s is
that I could have done more but I didn't
know that I could so I think it's that I
think you can do more than you think you
can that's what I would would like to
say in these areas of that you're
passionate about
you